[Musique]
bonsoir c'est un sujet peut-être un
petit peu plus grave que ce que vous
avez entendu précédemment différents qui
peut peut-être mettre mal à l'aise
certains mais je pense pas réellement
est donc ce soir moi je vais apporter
quelque chose qui concerne le regard
qu'on a face à la maladie la sienne et
celle des autres et je vais commencer
tout de suite par dire que il ya un mot
important dont on va parler ce soir
c'est la résilience c'est pas tout à
fait la renaissance la résilience à
pourrait s'appliquer à des métaux des
métaux qui reprennent leur forme après
une modification par exemple vous tirez
sur un ressort et le ressort se remet en
place
c'est ça une forme de résilience est au
fond la résilience pour nous être humain
c'est la capacité à revenir dans un état
antérieur après un traumatisme qu'ils
soient physiques ou psychologiques
alors un psychiatre est connu non vous
n'êtes peut-être plus est un ouvrage qui
s'appelle boris cyrulnik a remis ce mot
à la page
on en parle maintenant dans toutes les
toutes les discussions concernant les
traumatismes et les maladies graves les
attentats et la résilience c'est ça et
donc la résilience est une autre forme
de renaissance si on arrive à surmonter
un traumatisme encore une fois qu'ils
soient physiques mais aussi
psychologiques et c'est quelque chose
qui fait beaucoup réfléchir autour de
soi quand on a l'expérience de quelqu'un
qui dépasse quelque chose de difficile
on se dit est ce que j'aurais pu le
faire alors moi dans mon métier
effectivement je m'occupe pas des choses
les plus simples
80000 cancers digestifs par an en france
quinze mille cancer du pancréas dont je
suis le dépositaire pour beaucoup
d'entre eux puisque c'est ma grande
thématique c'est là dessus que je suis
connue la survie à 5 ans de ces cancers
est faible vous le savez on progresse
doucement mais c'est tout de même
évidemment des maladies dont on sort pas
ni vivent parfois ni en bon état général
donc si vous voulez c'est quelque chose
pour lequel on se pose cette question
est pourtant on apporte des choses aux
patients et nous apporte énormément dans
leur résidence a eu alors évidemment la
résilience dépend de la nature du
traumatisme
il est des petits traumatise simple on
joue au football on se fait une entorse
de la cheville ça nous arrive
régulièrement
on rate le match suivant c'est agaçant
mais c'est une petite résilience les
traumatismes sont plus lourds quand il
ya divorce que quelqu'un est partie du
couple quand il ya une maladie grave qui
laisse une séquelle
et puis on va très très loin dans la
résilience qui est parfois impossible
quand un enfant suscite par exemple dans
une famille et ce à tous les
psychologues savent que un enfant qui
reprend la vie que ses parents lui
redonner quelque chose pour lequel la
résilience et extraordinaire difficile
voire impossible et pourtant on doit
essayer ses forces et puisqu'on est des
êtres humains avec nos traumatismes
notre peur de la mort de la souffrance
d'être résilient la maladie quand elle
arrive c'est vraiment un bouleversement
dans la vie c'est un bouleversement
parce que tous les repères sont perdus
beaucoup d'entrées en tout cas quand
elle est grave
la peur de l'avenir le fait que le
travail une certaine sécurité
disparaissent et des cons et par an moi
en tout cas c'est ce que j'ai vécu mon
premier de mes quatre enfants c'est la
peur de moi est arrivé là au fond on
n'est pas indispensable mais il pourrait
se retrouver seul et c'est quelque chose
qui nous affecte tous les parents je
pense
inconsciemment c'est d'un bouleversement
grave parce que y'a aussi son regard sur
la santé qui change
tiens donc il croyait immortel
je suis
une finitude qui d'entre nous quand il
part le matin pense qui peut ne pas être
là le soir qu'on a en fait une banque
avec un conte illimité sur tous les
sujets jeunes aubois en plus faire de la
moto on peut tout faire
c'est pas à moi que ça arrivera et je
pense que quand on a été malade au
contenu un traumatisme grave
tout d'un coup on s'aperçoit qu'on est
faillible que notre corps à une finitude
et que finalement d'être en bonne santé
de se lever le matin de boire son café
d'aller à son travail d'embrasser ses
enfants et d'avoir un toit c'est
extraordinaire mais on n'arrive pas en
compte tous les jours parce qu'il ya
toujours un détail qui va nous embêter
un impôt par ci une voiture qui est mal
garées par là les tas de petites choses
qui nous empoisonnent la vie donc ce
bouleversement arrive et le regard des
autres change également et ça c'est
difficile c'est à dire que tout d'un
coup on apparaît fragile je crois que
c'est s'il le disait très bien tout à
l'heure une femme qui accouche et on la
regarde peut-être comme quelqu'un qui a
plus la même valeur marchande sur le
bruit de travail quelqu'un qui est
malade c'est un petit peu la même chose
il est touché dans sa fierté mais cole
lorsqu'ils exercent par exemple des
responsabilités il peut très bien être
vécu comme affaibli par le regard des
autres dix ans après la guérison de mon
cancer
j'ai un bon ami si je prenais pas dans
cette salle qui à chaque fois que je
rentre dans la pièce dit tu vas
t'asseoir voilà alors évidemment après
un semi marathon c'est toujours mieux de
pouvoir s'asseoir mais je pense que le
regard des gens change et il change
durablement
je parle pas seulement des assurances
qui vous font payer très très longtemps
quand vous avez une maladie et pas
forcément un cancer mais également du
regard des autres pour lequel vous avez
changé par lequel vous avez changé et ce
reflet parfois un petit peu difficile à
vivre
donc ce grand bouleversement il va
falloir le dépasser il va falloir faire
confiance faire confiance à autrui parce
que la première question qu'on se pose
c'est au fond la maladie est ce le
hasard ou scan cause les êtres humains
déteste les hasards ouf
sauf pour le jeu peut-être mais pour le
reste il aime comprendre je vais donner
un exemple simple faute voisin 60 ans
fume comme un sapeur trois paquets par
jour et tous il crache un peu de sang et
d'un cancer du poumon à wim fort il le
savait et lui-même parfois dit à sa
démarche
on sait que le cancer du col de l'utérus
c'est un virus qui le déclenche le plus
souvent là on a une cause et l'être
humain est plus à l'aise les plus à
l'aise même parfois dans l'agressivité
il l'a un peu cherché il a pas fait son
dépistage il a fumé là on est encore une
fois par an trop grande difficulté en
tours du but de la personne qui est
malade et on va pouvoir même peut-être
lui envoyer un tout petit peu de deux
regards de culpabilité plus difficiles
sont les causes - certaines la pollution
certains cancers le téléphone est ce que
ça donne des tumeurs au cerveau et sert
à l'alimentation les pesticides alors il
commence à y avoir des études qui
prouvent qu'il ya une toxicité des
pesticides qui entraîne un certain
nombre de maladies graves
cela étant ce qui est très difficile
c'est que ce qui est valable à l'échelle
d'une collectivité n'est pas forcément
valable à l'échelon individuel qui en
contact des pesticides va faire un
cancer qui au contact du tabac va faire
un cancer on ne le sait pas et ça c'est
déjà beaucoup plus difficile quand
quelqu'un est dans une population à
risque vague et attrapes cette maladie
pourquoi moi pourquoi pas lui
et puis la troisième type de cause alors
là on rentre plus dans l'irrationnel
c'est à dire peut-être fait quelque
chose de mal et que dieu punit dieu l'a
voulu
parfois les causes que moi je trouve
irrationnelle les astres n'étaient pas
bien conjuguer et puis une cause plus
difficile c'est le stress ah bah oui il
a fait un cancer où il a une malle grave
parce qu'il avait un stress si tous les
gens qui avaient un stress ou des stress
avait des maladies graves au même rythme
au même moment ça se saurait mais il est
vrai que ça tombe sur un sujet qui est
peut-être prédisposé à un moment donné
où il peut affaiblir son immunité
mais c'est très difficile d'expliquer ça
et de le comprendre et le l'affirmer
alors évidemment quand ta passion me dis
docteur j'ai jamais fumé j'ai jamais vu
je fais de la course à pied j'ai un
cancer alors la voix que chose que je
lui dis bah déjà vous avez 60 ans
voulait arrêter tu veux un an plus tôt
donc faut pas être complètement
pessimiste ensuite vous allez mieux
tolérer les traitements mais ça ne me
satisfait pas amplement bien sûr parce
qu'on ne maîtrise pas tout et parce
qu'un article au début de l'année 2015
par de généticiens très connus tomassi
tifo golstein qu'on publie dans une
grande revue scientifique qui s'appelle
size et qui dit les cancers sont tous dû
au hasard ou presque alors ça a été
levée de boucliers des épidémies
east en gros ceux qui fument s'ils ont
les bons chromosomes pas de problème et
puis ce qu'on a la chance d'avoir les
bons chromosomes même s'il mange bio ils
ont le cancer s'est heureusement pas
aussi simple que ça avec tout de même
ils ont très très loin dans
l'explication 10 ans 80% des cancers
seraient dus au hasard génétique à la
loterie complète avec parfois quelques
formes familiales rare mais pour le
reste l'environnement qu'on ne peut
évidemment c'est très contestable parce
que la méthodologie de cet article peut
être contesté que pour autant on va pas
se mettre tout savoir et fumé demain en
excès en tout cas et donc ça le hasard
c'est encore une fois une des choses les
plus difficiles à supporter alors après
une fois que la mairie est là qu est ce
qu on peut avoir comme soutien et je
dirais qu est ce que vous pouvez
apporter comme soutien parce que c'est
un sujet qui est pas tellement abordés
on parle beaucoup comment un malade peut
se défendre face à son agression quelles
sont les recettes les pistes alors les
bouquins sur ce qu'il faut manger comme
tomates comme on se bat croûte grand
patron qui veut dire que c'est les
tomates cuites les autres les tomates
crues ou prévenir pour guérir bon je
rentre pas dans cette discussion qui me
paraît spécieuse et surtout commerciale
mais réellement je pense qu'on peut se
poser la question de soutenir quelqu'un
qui est malade et on a là tous autour de
soi une maladie peut être aiguë très
brutale d'un accident elle peut être
chronique et c'est parfois plus
difficile car au fond la première
question à se poser quand votre conjoint
votre ami votre fils votre proche voisin
vous dis je suis tombé malade et c'est
grave
la première question à se poser je pense
et qui suis-je par rapport à lui quand
je suis tombé malade
j'ai reçu des coups de fil de gens
totalement inattendue des gens qui
honnêtement n'étais pas dans mon premier
2 deuxième cercle il ya même une
personne qui m'a appelé deux fois par
jour alors que c'était quelqu'un de
distant qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans ses
appels il y avait une volonté d'aider il
y avait une volonté de voir ce que ça
fait de l'intérieur réfléchissons à sa
pensée aussi que vous pouvez être le
conjoint est parfois curieusement celui
qui est malade ou celle qui est malade
va plutôt avoir besoin de son copain
d'enfance
parce qu'un copain d'enfance ou une
copine d'enfance qui a vécu des choses
très fortes a parfois plus d'impact dans
l'amitié dans l'affectif que quelqu'un
qu'on côtoie au quotidien
habib très proches et même famille donc
au fond
arrivé à sentir qui je suis et comment
je vais pouvoir aider et comment pouvoir
aider d'abord la communication un sujet
très vaste
la communication c'est je prends mon
téléphone a dit non il paraît que c'est
un cancer
voilà c'est pas très agréable pouvoir
sauver 51 coups de fil les quatre
premiers jours parce que ces coups de
fils vont s'amenuiser très vite et qu'
il faudra compter toujours là mais
l'histoire c'est pénible
il faut donner une idée de la gravité
une idée du diagnostic
une idée du comment est d'abord qu'est
ce que c'est que ce cancer souvent les
gens savent pas c'est pas toujours un
cancer du sein qui peut facilement être
compris même par un homme ça arrive ça
peut être un cancer plus difficile à
expliquer ou une maladie grave plus
difficile à expliquer et quand le
pronostic est pas sûr c'est difficile de
répondre
alors quand on a la double casquette etc
on est médecin et qu'on s'occupe de
cancer tout au long de la journée même
si t'es pas tout à fait le même
alors raconte moi comment ça s'attrape
mais qu'est ce que tu dois faire comme
traitement tu vas en guérir pas en
guérir donc au fond la double casquette
en l'occurrence et c'est valable pour
tous les soignants
selon les médecins c'est il faut que je
rassure tout en rassurant tout en étant
inquiets donc c'est un petit peu
compliqué à gérer mais ça ça arrive à
des gens qui ne sont pas dans le milieu
soignants et qui eux mêmes ont fort à
faire face donc un texto ça peut être
très bien j'ai appris que tu étais
malade dit moi quand tu as besoin de moi
une lettre en sachant qu'il ne faut pas
attendre de réponse une lettre c'est un
aller simple
j'ai appris que tu étais malade j'habite
à 800 kilomètres ça fait deux ans qu'on
s'est pas vu ça me ferait vraiment
plaisir que tu ailles bien je ne sais
pas du tout ce que tu as mais je suis
près de toi et si tu veut m'appeler
appelle moi et quand tu ira mieux tu me
le diras j'irai le voir autre forme
louis le sms à ses formidables tu vas
bien quand j'ai eu mon cancer un des
copains m'a dit j'ai une petite histoire
pour toi l'histoire du cochon du
sanglier vous la connaissez peut-être
tout cas je l'aï écrit dans mon livre
alors je me dis qu'il va me raconter une
histoire drôle eh oui il a raconté une
histoire drôle d'ailleurs devant ensuite
tous mes collègues du goût du boulot
alors c'est le cochon et sangliers à la
sortie de la forêt et de sangliers en
garde le cochon avec tendresse lui pose
la main sur l'épaule sur l'épaule du
cochon il y alors tu as fini ta
chimiothérapie
et il l'a raconté comme ça devant mes
sept ou huit collègues effaré les deux
collègues qui pleurait et quand j'ai
annoncé mon cancer il a ressorti le
courage de le faire
je peux vous garantir qu'un peu d'humour
c'est pas mal hein c'est pas mal j'ai un
autre collègue qui m'a dit ma quatrième
chimiothérapie tu vas l'enterrement de
ton dernier globules blancs alors que
tout le monde était pétrifié quand on
est un aplat ions la zéro défense si on
est un petit peu peur ça fait un bien
fou et je pense que quand on est capable
de recevoir ça il faut quelqu'un vous
connaissent bien certains n'ont pas
l'humour dans ces moments difficiles et
je pense que le mourre peut être une
arme extraordinaire dont communiqué
aider soutenir c'est d'abord se poser la
question de qui je suis de ce que je
sais et de ce que je peux dire c'est pas
facile pour des soignants de soutenir
quand ils ont une idée du pronostic mais
au fond la meilleure question à poser
c'est plutôt que de dire j'ai trouvé de
recettes
ça peut être de l'amour je t'ai trouvé
un docteur qui est beaucoup mieux que
celui que tu as c'est souvent les gens
viennent en deuxième troisième attention
j'ai entendu dire cueille les soigner là
bas juste à côté il a tous les
traitements moselle le professeur mais
il faut absolument qu'il vous voit très
bien c'est de l'amour les gelée royale
ma voisine m'a apporté des gelées royal
tous les jours les brésiliennes elle
faisait un breuvage extraordinaire
qu'elle m'a apporté dans un pot en métal
c'était bon c'était frais quand on a
plus de plus de plus de lèvres plus rien
parce qu'on a là tout est irritée tout
est abîmée
ça fait beaucoup de bien dit c'est ça
qui va te dirai pour le chimiothérapie
voilà ça c'est de l'amour aussi
et je pense que toutes ces
manifestations il faut les accepter mais
fou elles peuvent aussi être refusée
parce que certaines des manifestations
d'affection peuvent être dangereuses
tu prends pas le bon docteur tu prends
pas le bon traitement je te recommande
si je te recommande sa grâce à on est
abreuvé de conseil y compris quand on
est médecin donc soutenir
c'est une proximité c'est une présence
c'est de l'amour mais c'est aussi du
silence
une des choses qui m'a le plus
bouleversé moi personnellement dans ma
maladie c'est quand une de mes collègues
qui avait été totalement silencieuse qui
avait pas fait signe
quand je suis revenu au bout de
c'est un peu plus de six mois myskreen
lettre en disant je ne savais pas que
dire je ne sais pas comment parler mais
j'étais toujours avec toi et ça je
trouve que c'est extrêmement touchants
et parfois le silence et d'une aide
formidable alors après la guérison peut
survenir
évidemment je suis un privilégié on
n'est pas des héros il ya 350 mille
nouvelles personnes en france qui ont un
cancer chaque année beaucoup en
guérissent porteurs n'ont pas toujours
certaines vivent avec pour montrer
longtemps alors guérir oui mais c'est
pas si facile quand une femme accouche
on dit alors tu es content tu as eu ton
bébé et le lendemain elle est en larmes
avec son début dans un post partum blues
parce que tout s'écroule
mais quand on a pensé pendant des mois
quelque chose quand on a préparé un
examen il ya beaucoup de gens dans cette
salle quand on a attendu un bébé ou
quand on est un maladie grave est qu
elle disparaît il ya quelque chose d'un
vide qui se créent considérable qu'est
ce que je veux faire de ma vie
maintenant tout le monde se désintéresse
de vous au début à l'aller coup de
téléphone l'affection et sert à haïti
les mobilisations pour ce drame
phénoménal début 2011 deux mois plus
tard le tsunami au japon
trois lignes sur haïti dans les journaux
alors que les quatre cent mille morts et
toute leur famille étaient toujours là
vous vous avez votre maladie plus
personne ne s'intéresse à vous vous êtes
guéri ça va on passe à autre chose le
voisin à le voisin il a quelque chose tu
as vu donc ça c'est très difficile à
vivre avec le souvenir de ce qu'on a été
et le fait qu'on soit guérie savez vous
que chez les jeunes qui ont une maladie
de hodgkin c'est derek ancien des
ganglions
le taux de suicide est multiplié par
trois au moment où leur médecin leur dis
j'ai plus besoin de vous suivre vous
êtes certainement guéri et à ce moment
là c'est étonnant il ya un vide qui se
crée il ya toute cette attente
toute cette concentration sur une chose
alors parfois c'est un heureux événement
tout une grossesse un examen réussi et
le vide ton derrière dans une maladie
c'est de cet ordre là nous on avance
avec une cicatrice que les autres ne
voient pas et ils se complaisent à vous
dire que vous êtes bien vous êtes guéri
que tout va bien et ça faut toujours et
penser alors cela étant moi je pense que
c'est une expérience formidable moment
riche parce que évidemment je vais la
chance de guérir et les patients ne
peuvent pas tout se dire ça donc
s'effacer facile à dire quand on est
sorti mais il ya quand même des choses
qui ont été difficiles j'ai grandi
énormément je pense que tous les gens
grandit pas seulement dans un
traumatisme physique mais aussi un
traumatisme psychologique
moi je crois réellement qu'on apprend
dans ses difficultés liées à un vrai
manque on apprend beaucoup
qu'on a une certaine acceptation puisque
les musulmans disent le mektoub c'est
dieu qui l'a voulu
nietzsche a dit m ton destin et moi
j'aime mon destin parce que je pense que
si je n'avais pas eu cette maladie en
2004 au coeur de ma vie alors que quand
même deux enfants étaient à la
maternelle si je me souviens solange
deux autres étaient pas grand non plus
j'ai grandi j'ai grandi dans mon métier
alors je suis pas très différent d'avant
je vais là même peut-être juste vouloir
me est pareil mais peut-être l'écouté
différentes et young a dit on c'est bien
le patient sait bien qui a souffert
quand il a un thérapeute en face qu'il
soit de quelque nature qu'elle que ce
soit comme thérapeute il le sent et il
ya quelque chose qui se passe alors dans
la vie de tous les jours moi je dis que
c'est une grande chance quand on a
surmonté ce genre de choses et tout le
monde surmonte ses malheurs plus ou
moins grands et nietzsche a dit tout ce
qui ne tue pas rend plus fort c'est vrai
mais après c'est ça la renaissance je
pense qu'on peut repartir j'ai pu écrire
un livre j'en écris un deuxième j'ai
repris la musique je fais plein d'autres
choses et est finalement oui c'est une
renaissance alors avec de la chance au
milieu de sa vie il ya des gens à qui ça
arrive plus tard plus tôt et voilà donc
c'est ça l'expérience que je voulais
partager avec vous mais c'est une belle
expérience
merci
[Applaudissements]